seltenste pokemon ktm evolution display
gezogen riesiges pech opening opening
die 200.000 dollar first edition pokémon
box auf fische livestream poetry
hunderttausend dollar pokémon kartons
first edition packs hier wird eine
blu-ray selten für 500.000 euro auf ebay
verkauft und 1999 werden da sind ob
dortmund gestohlen eine box mit 400.000
dollar verkauft und dir wird der neue
rekorde aufgestellt was die box und
bogen und garten bei einer auktion
angeht
ist los mit der welt führen wir dafür
einer gesagt hätte
als ich zehn jahre alt war
ich hätte nicht mehr arbeiten müssen
ich glaube jeder der nicht komplett
hinter mond lebt hat sie den letzten
wochen beziehungsweise monaten schon
mitbekommen dass pokémon karten
beziehungsweise mittlerweile generell
sammelkarte von früher um geheime an
wert gewonnen haben und ich selber bin
ebenfalls eine riesige pokemon fan ich
habe zwar immer noch mehr yu-gi-oh
damals geguckt und gesammelt aber
pokémon war mein leben ich hatte jedes
spiel alles ich war sogar so verknallt
dass ich mir so einen pokédex irgendwann
mal selbst gebastelt habe als ich das
ist über die letzten wochen so
mitbekommen habe mit ihnen welchen
tritsch zuschauerrekorde gebrochen
werden mit leuten die da millionen
aufrufe machen nur weil sie quasi karten
öffnen habe ich mir gedacht hey ich habe
bestimmt bei meiner familie zu hause in
bielefeld auch noch richtig viele karten
rom fliegen
also habe ich meine angeschrieben und
meinte hey schau mal im keller bei
meinen spielzeug boxen ob du da
vielleicht pokémon karten findest und
was schickt mir meine mutter das ja der
große galileo chemiebaukasten minecraft
lego edition oder irgendeinen pampers
spielen das kann erzählen
sie mir ein foto von der beschriftung
des nächsten kartons geschickt da war
das drin matchbox-autos siku straßen
tempi straßen teppich der also der wert
steigen dann so geil diese straßen
teppiche dann mit meinem arm auf jeden
fall den nächsten karton geöffnet und da
war das drin eine minecraft spitzhacke
doch dann lieben freunde hat er meine
man eine nachricht geschrieben und
meinte luca ich aber ein sammelalbum
gefunden und ich dachte mir nur so jetzt
geht's los
ich richte millionen ich sie schon das
glitzernde grad vor mir wenigstens war
da noch ein bisschen geld drin
[Musik]
pokémon ist der schritt den wir brauchen
schickt sie mir das also ignoriert
nintendogs dackel edition da oben aber
pokémon platin nintendo ds mama das
kriegst du nicht mehr verkauft wenn du
leuten geld und ob gibst auch dann weil
ich zu ihr hey mama wenn da nichts
pokémon mäßiges ist vielleicht noch
yukio yuan allerdings nicht kennen ist
ein anime und habe ich früher normal
gesucht und ich wollte immer diese des
karben habe ich nie bekommen wenn man
jetzt auch für mehr geld verkaufen ich
will nicht sagen
auf jeden fall meine mom ihn an das foto
hier geschickt also wieder einen karton
von mir mit der beschriftung yu gi oh
karten ja ich hatte tausende aber wusste
nicht mal view bio richtig geschrieben
wird doch dann ging's los meine lieben
freunde
sie hat den karton aufgemacht nicht dass
das ja das ist eine drachen blue eyes
war weit strecken irgendwie so heißt sie
und ich meine der so mama komm hol'
raushole raus die karten ich will das
sehen wieviel geldes als dingwerth und
schickt sie mir das ignoriert bitte den
geheimagenten ausweis da rechts denn
hier liegt der
kreisweit dragon doch das war
tatsächlich das letzte foto was mit
meinem namen dann gestern abend
geschickt hat denn dann ist sie schlafen
gegangen
ja ich konnte das nicht auf mir sitzen
lassen habe dann mit einigen kumpels
gefälscht und wir haben einfach mal
gegoogelt was in so die wertvollsten yu
gi oh karten und siehe da das meine
karte auf platz 2 der wertvollsten yu gi
oh karten
ich will dich sagen aber ich glaube ich
also ich meine doch dann haben uns mal
ein bisschen informiert und haben
gesehen dass meine blue eyes soweit zu
dragon karte auf ebay für 699 euro
gehandelt wird und damit noch nicht
genug
ein paar minuten später haben wir sogar
dieses dingsbums gesehen
25.000 euro das sind 25 mal 1000 euro
und 1000 euro sind 1000 cheeseburger so
ich werd reich dachte ich mir weil
die schlafen gegangen und beim
einschlafen und ich halt die ganze zeit
diesen freudigen gedanken menschlich
werde reich wenn diese eine karte die
meine mutter geschickt hat allein schon
25.000 euro kostet dann ist das erst der
anfang
das ist das ist erst die halfpipe auf
meinem stand zum glück in den himmel
ja damit hat morgen aufgewacht meine
mama hat mir genau wo fotos von der
karte geschickt und es ist also so sieht
sie halt aus von hinten sieht sie so aus
und das ding ist dann dass ich dann noch
mal ein bisschen genauer an mir die
bezeichnung angeguckt habe also meine
jetzt auch auf ebay gehandelt allerdings
eher so für 1 euro 50 dann auch ich habe
mich davon nicht unterkriegen lassen und
haben einmal gesagt heute dann nochmal
heute morgen geh dann noch mal herunter
die normativ vereinen die bücher in die
kartons dar und es steht mir mal was da
noch so rumliegt dann hat es mir das
sehr geschickt das sind tatsächlich dann
auch alles leider nur verpackungen
doch dann hat es mir auch noch passier
geschickt seht ihr schon da sind ganz
viele karten sind da und ein video
da das allerdings alles yu gi oh karten
waren meinte ich dann einfach nutzen
meiner mama wenn du jetzt so viele
karten irgendwie doch noch gefunden hast
hast du da vielleicht auch irgendwie
pokemon sachen dabei und nicht nur diese
yu gi oh karten was schickt mit meinem
arm dass das hier und das
doch davon hat sich meine mutter
nach sage und schreibe 34 minuten hatte
geschriebene luca pokémon paten gefunden
fünfstück fünf karten 5 sandras zeugnis
durchschnitt ich habe meiner mum dann
gesagt ich hatte doch früher circa
200.000 harten aber wo sind die acht die
er beim trödelmarkt mehr verschenkt
dennoch habe ich mir dann in meinem
falls so ausgemalt mensch luca
vielleicht habe ich ja gerade die fünf
karten behalten
die irgendwie am krassesten waren damals
gegen die sonne glitzern des blu-ray
passieren vielleicht eine halbe million
verkaufen kann
nagl ob eine tankkarte lampions glück
und straff wickel nur scheiße könnte
auf einer villa auf den malediven sitzen
mit einem cocktail in der hand und mehr
dessen wir rechts dem ich denke nur noch
55 pokemon karten und das alles an yu gi
oh
insgesamt sei das bei mir da so aus als
meine mom laster alles durch geld hat
hat irgendjemand von den leuten geradezu
schon habt ihr ahnung von yu-gi-oh ist
das auch so viel wert wie pokemon bitte
memorial talk ich habe mir überlegt zu
meiner familie nach bielefeld zu fahren
und allem einer alten karte mitzunehmen
nach hamburg und schlechte karte was
wert und verlosen einen von euch oder so
wenn ihr bock habt ich habe wie gesagt
auch schon mit freunden dazu gefällt ein
kollege von mir einfach dass hier zu
hause das hier und auch beispielsweise
die hier einfach fucking youtube alter
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich habe absolut
keine ahnung davon welche karte viel
wert ist welche wenig wert ist ich hab
früher auf dem schulhof halt immer so 50
tränke gegen eine glitzernde getauscht
ich habe auch nie pokémon karten selbst
gespielt oder you go kart ich gehe
einfach nur gesammelt
ja ich wollte einfach nur meinen beitrag
so ein bisschen dazu geben zu dem ganzen
kreis hier weil ich ja den letzten tagen
auch so ein bisschen meiner instagram
story gepostet habe ich meine man die
sachen zusammengesucht hat also wenn
euch meinen recap von diesem ganzen
pokemon jugo thema gefallen hat das
gerne daumen hoch und ein video da
schreibt mir und in die kommentare
ob ich diese karten mal holen soll ob
ich mit einem kollegen zusammen video
machen soll der unfassbar viele alte
pokémon karten hat aber auch gar keine
ahnung davon hat und wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen wollte
besser auf
[Musik]